these lemon ricotta souffle pancakes
will have everyone asking to come over
for brunch at least that's what they did
for me I love the tanginess that the
lemon adds to these and while the
ricotta makes them slightly denser than
traditional Japanese souffle pancakes it
also ensures they're super rich and
moist make sure to not over mix and
deflate your egg whites as you combine
all the ingredients to maintain that
nice souffle texture and timing the
cooking and flipping the pancakes are
definitely the trickiest parts here so
be sure to check out my written recipe
for these but when you get the hang of
it you're left with these beautifully
puffy pancakes perfect for spring and
sharing so it's no surprise that